في مجلس الامن اليوم حضرت ايسومي انك متسو
وكيله الامين العام للامم المتحده لشؤون
المنازع السلاح حضرت من ان خطر استخدام
سلاح نوويا في الوقت الحالي اعلى من اي
وقت مضى منذ الحرب البارده جاء ذلك في
الجلسه التي دعت اليها اوكرانيا والولايات
المتحده والمانيا بشان نيه روسيا نشر
اسلحه النوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا
ان خطر استخدام سلاح نووي اعلى حاليا من
اي وقت مضى منذ الحرب البارده تمثل الحرب
في اوكرانيا المثال الاكثر حده لهذا الخطر
ان غياب الحوار والتاكل هيكل نزع السلاح
الى جانب الخطاب الخطير والتهديدات
المستتره هي دوافع رئيسيه لهذا الخطر
الوجودي المحتمل من اجل امننا الجماعي
اجدد تاكيد دعوه الامين العام الاتحاد
الروسيه والولايات المتحده للعوده الى
التنفيذ الكامل لمعاهده ستارت الجديده
وبدء المفاوضات بشان خليفتها